Unlike in live action,
cinematography,
lighting in animation,
it's something that's built totally from
scratch.
In other words,
well in live action,
light is controlled sometimes too
brilliant effect in animation.
Light is created.
Of course these days a lot of animated
light is computer generated,
meaning that virtual lights can be
placed in three d environments and
actually play off solid surfaces like
they would in real life,
like the control of actual lights.
This too can be used to beautiful
effect,
but today I want to talk about lighting
as it was done in traditional hand drawn
cell animation,
particularly in the groundbreaking anime
film by Ketso Hero Tomo,
Akira.
Now Kira is well known for it's
painstaking animation.
Every frame of the film was composed
with the closest attention to detail and
color and that gives it an unmatched
richness and soul.
For this reason,
the cure,
it is also a film that's been
painstakingly picked over and analyze by
others,
but one thing I haven't heard much about
is the way that lighting is used by the
filmmakers.
Because I see the films,
many lights.
There are different qualities and
textures as a powerful motif and symbol
and a vital element of it's genius
backgrounds must still be photographed
by the master camera in technicolor.
Yeah.
They operate with the Donald Duck on top
of a background as the overhead camera
exposures.
One frame of film,
like I said,
Akira was a film made in the cell
animation style developed in the first
half of the 20th century,
which involves drawing and painting on a
transparent slides and layering them
over a background frames composed like
this were photographed and strung
together to create the animation.
This Two d traditional style coupled
with the tropes of anime means that the
light and Akira is specific and
pronounce the lines between shadow and
light,
are distinct and evocative in the same
way that film noir lighting is and like
in film noir light and Akira is
intimately connected to the city at
night.
This for example,
is the very first shot after the opening
credits of flickering neon sign for the
neighborhood bar.
Where can neda is waiting for his
friends?
Nothing could more concisely communicate
the rundown dystopic feeling of the
future.
Tokyo Tomo is going to present us with
in the very next shot and throughout the
film.
Indeed,
this is a city as sorted romantic and
multifarious as the lights that slash
across it's million surfaces to make a
delicate whole,
the city where the disenfranchised young
mark their presence and their
personalities with the streaks of light
that their motorcycles leave behind the
city where authority is as much a
blinding spotlight as it is a gun or a
badge.
Oh,
Tomo has said that he wanted Tokyo
itself to be a major character and Akira
and one of the ways he flushes this out
is with light,
particularly neon neon has a special
significance for both Tokyo and the
cyberpunk genre.
It is the bitter but beautiful that
signifies both the colorful radiance and
the Gadi consumerism of modernity.
That dark dystopian side of which remain
cyberpunks basic focus.
Tokyo for its part,
has been a cultural hub for neon signage
ever since 1957.
When the Sukkot company unveiled its
giant 30 foot neon billboard in the
Ginza district revealing its new name.
Sony.
Since then,
the science have proliferated becoming a
signature,
even a tourist attraction of Tokyo's
nightscape and novels like William
Gibson's neuromancer films like blade
runner took the vivid and suggestive
qualities of Tokyo's neon as their
palate for oblique tech.
Saturated future,
Akira continues this tradition,
but here are the neon quality,
infuses all the light sources of the
film,
both inside and out.
There's the neon on the buildings,
but there's also the neon bright screens
that shine and the characters faces and
the neon control panels of bright
primary colors.
The spotlights that rove in the sky are
like giant neon tubes being waved back
and forth.
Machine gun fire is a barrage of neon
streaks.
Even the sunlight shining through the
windows has a bluish neon quality to it.
In neon neo,
Tokyo and its inhabitants aren't so much
lit as caught caught in this huge
incandescent web that serves only the
mandates of money capital in that web
government is as impotent as a biker
gang made up of disaffected children.
It's funny that industry business is
notably absent from the films plot
because it's DNA seems to be in the
corners of everything.
We blink and you might miss a newsreader
at the beginning of the movie shining
from another flickering lights,
source reporting riots of unemployed
workers after tax reforms.
Maybe this is why tetsuo at once,
the protagonist and the antagonist of
the film,
a boy who gains extremely Mary psychic
power so often produces a disruption in
the light around him,
whether it's in his own mind or in the
form of explosion or in the aura around
him,
even in the vibrant dancing waveland
that his brain patterns create indeed
psychic power most fully realized in
Tetsuo and his counterpoint,
Akira represent the only kind of power
that can have an effect on the state of
things.
In Neo Tokyo.
This is perhaps the reason that the
protesters turned to Akira for their
salvation because even when the
authorities turned their biggest
spotlight on him,
a mega satellite laser that takes the
name of our son,
he comes out the victor.
In the end,
the salvation represented in Tetsuo
comes at the cost of ruin.
A catastrophe which consumes neo Tokyo
in the form of a giant ball of light,
one single uniform white light that
erases the countless artificial lights
of the city.
Oh,
Tomo seems to suggest that there's some
freedom in this,
some rebirth as true sunlight wipes
across the city in patches.
When you have to draw light 24 times in
every second of a two hour movie,
it must be the case that you gain a new
appreciation for how it can tell the
story of its own and that's what our
Tomo and his crew have done and Akira
light is layered into the story like
it's layered into the animation cells
pointing toward meaning behind the film,
at the corners of it,
and illuminating from different angles,
the characters and their place in this
neon world.
In other words,
a Kira is a great example of how you
animate light.
Everybody.
It is great to be back home,
back to work,
and back on schedule.
Finally,
you want to subscribe to the channel.
By the way,
you can click right there.
That box over there.
I have to thank crunchy roll for
sponsoring this video.
If you don't know what control is,
it's like a great service where you can
access tons of different anime shows and
movies.
Obviously I love and May I love Akira,
but you can get stuff like an hour after
it airs on TV in Japan on crunchy roll.
I want to recommend one.
It's cowboy bebop.
You haven't seen it.
It is an amazing,
amazing show.
Might actually analyze it sometime in
the future,
but um,
anyway,
they're a great service.
They do really hd episodes.
You can get it on apple TV or Roku or
whatever you have and if you sign up at
[inaudible] dot com slash nerd writer,
you can get a free 30 day trial,
which is awesome.
And they're awesome for sponsoring the
show without interfering in the content
in any way or asking to.
Thank you guys for that.
And I'll see everybody else next
Wednesday.